MICHAEL WEISS-MALIK:
Hi everybody.
Hear me OK?
OK, so I think we're
going to get going.
My name's Michael Weiss-Malik.
Our guest today,
Jonathan Kuniholm.
I met him in we think 2007--
as far as we can piece back
together-- at a
SciFoo conference
and he had some pretty cool
tech that he was demoing.
Some open source robotics
stuff related to prosthetics.
And I was impressed
enough that I said,
hey you should come and give
a talk at Google some time.
And he took that to heart and
about four or five years later
emailed me and said, hey you
offered that talk at Google,
now would be a great time.
So so we're hosting him today.
Jonathan is the president and
founder of the open prosthetics
project.
He's also a founder of
StumpworX, a startup that
focuses on prosthetic
technology.
He's also presidential appointee
to the National Council
on Disability.
And the stuff he has
to say is pretty cool.
So please put your
hands together
and help me welcome Jon.
JON KUNIHOLM: Thanks
very much, Michael.
Let me first just
offer a disclaimer
with respect to my
government job--
they encourage us to do this--
that everything that I'm
going to say today
are my personal views
and not reflective of any
position of the government.
So what I would like
to talk about today
is how we can design good
design to solve problems
that society has for
the most part neglected.
And I came across
one of those problems
personally after I
lost my arm in 2005
and discovered that
prosthetic arms were
an orphan medical device.
And in thinking
a little bit more
about why prosthetic arms lagged
so far behind other technology
that we use every day,
I started to realize
that prosthetic arms and
orphan medical devices
are part of a larger
group of those problems
that society has
tended to neglect,
which can be solved by
something that we're beginning
to call public interest design.
And the question that I'd really
like to talk about today--
and I would actually
like it to be
the beginning of a discussion
because it's something that
by no means I claim to
have even begun to solve--
is, how can we marshal
all of the tools
at our disposal to trying to
better solve those problems.
Because very much now I believe
that most of those problems
are solved in kind
of a haphazard way.
Government funded projects,
philanthropy, side
projects from industry.
You name the way that people
happen upon these issues
and try to solve them,
but in general you
can be sure that the resources
and attention that we devote
toward solving these
underserved needs
are going to lag far
behind those problems which
are very obvious from every
other standpoint need solving.
Very profitable things.
There was no question
that cell phone technology
was going to improve over the
last 10 years, for example.
So in the summer of 2005 I
took leave from graduate school
at Duke University and I was
deployed as a marine to Iraq
in Anbar Province.
And I was the platoon commander
for an engineer position of 50
Marines and we were doing
mostly what everybody
was doing over there, which
was sustainment and stability
operations, patrolling, guarding
convoys, that sort of thing.
On New Year's day of 2005
I was on a foot patrol
that was ambushed by
improvised explosive device.
The blast took off
most of my forearm
and I found myself back
in the States and learning
about prosthetic arm technology.
I managed to get
myself back to school
and get involved with a
research project sponsored
by DARPA called the
Revolutionizing Prosthetics
2009 Project.
It was one of two that
DARPA was funding.
Which is really the first
serious prosthetic arm research
effort that had occurred
in the United States
since-- there was a
small one in the '70s--
but really since World War II.
The goal was a
really ambitious one.
The goal was to create--
in four years, in 2007--
an arm using commercially
available technology
that could go to market
in that year, in 2007.
And then more
ambitiously to create
an arm that had more
degrees of freedom,
was fully in neurally
integrated-- so
nearly the same articulation
as a native human arm--
and full strength.
An incredibly ambitious project.
What I think it's
important to understand
there's been an enormous--
and this picture
is up here not too bag
that I was on 60 Minutes,
but to show the
kind of attention
to that these projects got.
For whatever reason,
prosthetic arms
tend to really capture
the popular imagination.
People love robotics.
They love thinking about the
barriers, the singularity
and the barriers between man
and machine disappearing.
It becomes a vehicle for
all kinds of philosophical
and science fiction interest.
I think the takeaway about
these projects, which
is important to
remember is first of all
that despite the amazing things
that both of these research
efforts accomplished,
we still have not--
more than 10 years since the
war began in Afghanistan,
actually pushing 15
now-- still do not
have any commercially
available device that's
resulted from any of this
government funded research.
We're still waiting
for the first one.
It has remained, as always,
just around the corner.
And I'm told that we're waiting
on FDA approval for the DECA RP
'07 project to
receive FDA approval.
And it has been
some clinical trials
but we still haven't
seen a device.
The other one is
I think that it's
important to understand-- it's
my belief that we have a media
bias.
It's not a political
conservative media bias,
but it's one towards
entertainment.
And so the word
bionic is used a lot,
the words dexterous
and manipulation
are also used a lot, which
have very specific meanings
in robotics.
There are some caveats
that I could give.
You could call a trigger
grip for example,
where one part of
the hand is grasping
a handle of a cordless
drill and the finger is
pulling the trigger.
That tends toward
sort of manipulation.
It's at least a compound grasp.
For one part of
your hand is doing
one thing and one doing another.
Of course the slide that
I'm showing here right now
gives you some insight into what
the human hands are capable of.
This pair of hands
is doing a card trick
where four cuts of the
deck are being controlled
by different parts
of the two hands
and it's a dynamic movement.
I guarantee you that there isn't
a robotic hand of any kind that
could do these card
tricks right now.
But based on the popular
press presentation of all this
you would think that it can.
You would think that
these problems are solved.
So while I think it's important
to acknowledge the strides that
were made by these
research projects,
it's also very
important to understand
that we are not there yet.
And we do not have
bionic people.
And these hands are for
the most part right now,
I think that it would be fair
to say, at least in terms
of prosthetic control that even
these highly articulated hands
are really only
capable of grasping.
And the difference between
grasping and manipulation I
think you can use a
Rubik's cube to illustrate.
Manipulation is a speed
cuber solving a Rubik's cube
in a few minutes and
grasping is not dropping it.
And grasping a Rubik's
cube is actually something
that I can do with
the hook that I
wear when I do wear
a prosthetic arm.
Which is the Dorrance
5x named after the guy
who patented in 1912.
And you can see that since
then it's evolved a little bit.
There's some rubber grip on
the fingers a cigarette notch--
and I think it's
called a pen notch now.
But this remains
despite everything
that's happened the most
used prosthetic terminal
device in America.
And were you to go to the
Myoelectric conference
in New Brunswick in Canada this
August it would be a fair bet
to make that the majority
of amputees attending
the conference-- at least
the ones who weren't paid
to be there by a
prosthetic company--
would be wearing
one of these devices
and not any of the
robotic prosthetic hands
that are available.
The other thing that's
important to note about this
is that there's another
choice which actually beats
all of them, which is the
one that I'm wearing today,
which is nothing.
About half of all arm
amputees choose most times not
to wear prosthesis at all.
And it's mostly because
of weight and comfort
in suspension and I'm going to
talk about that a little bit
later.
Now why is all of that?
This is by no means an
attack on any the folks
who were generous enough
to fund that project
and try to make some progress.
The real problem is that
they're there simply
isn't a market for these things.
The market for powered arms
it is just barely noise
compared to these
other large markets.
And even though the government
has accomplished quite a bit
in some of these
research projects, what
we call the valley of death,
which is the bridge that one
of these products must cross
in order to get from the lab
into becoming a clinical
product is really significant.
And without a market to
drive further funding,
that gap-- which is estimated
by people in the industry
to be something like
90% of the R&D remaining
on a medical product once a
proof of principal device is
finished-- there's just simply
nowhere for those resources
to come from and make it happen.
Correspondingly,
the amount of effort
that's actually put into
solving this problem
is also very small.
Compared to-- I cherry picked
a few really large government
sponsored engineering projects.
Some of which have been compared
to this DARPA prosthetics
project.
This is all in 2006 dollars.
The Manhattan Project
comes in over $20 billion,
the moon race over $120 billion,
and just the R&D for the Joint
Strike Fighter at
over $40 billion.
And so the $100 million, while
more than anybody had spent on
and on prosthetic arms in half
a century, the DARPA spend
is basically just
noise compared to this.
And I would argue that the
task that they set out to solve
rivals some of these in
terms of the engineering
effort required.
I mean it's a small project and
it and instead of a large one.
But nevertheless an enormous
portion of our brains,
for example, is devoted to
the control of our hands
in manipulation.
I don't know if
you all have ever
seen-- I don't have
a slide of it here--
but the homunculus that neural
researchers use to represent.
They take a human figure and
adjust him proportionally
based on the number
of nerve endings
in some studies of the brain.
So this little figure has
gigantic lips, gigantic hands,
and depending on whether you're
looking at the censored version
or not, gigantic
genitalia, reflecting
how much of our
brains are devoted
to control these
parts of our body.
And this is true both in
terms of motor control
and sensory control,
it works both ways.
And as you can see from that
slide of the card trick,
feedback-- sensory
feedback-- is certainly
a huge part of our hands
being able to do what we do.
So what we have is
a three-way market
failure to solve this problem.
Industry, government, and
academia all doing their parts
but all unable to
solve this problem.
But of course it's
completely understandable
and that's why we
call prosthetic arms
an orphan device.
The orphan drug law that was
passed in 1983 defined patients
in need of a drug as
being medical orphans
of their patient population
was less than 250,000.
So prosthetic arms
in the United States
are about a couple
years ago, 43,000.
So fewer than 50,000 patients
in the United States.
That's a sixth of the maximum
threshold for being an orphan.
Of course the orphan drug law
covers pharmaceuticals and not
medical devices.
So we don't have a companion
regulation or law or anything
that covers the creation
of medical devices.
And another peculiarity
of course of that,
is how we pay for medical
devices in the United States.
And get to that will get
to that a little bit later.
So as I mentioned before,
all of these medical orphans
and the NIH-- and this includes
all of the orphan drug patient
populations and others--
the NIH lists something
like 10,000 orphaned
conditions on its website.
And because I happened to be
interested in prosthetic arms
I searched for limb
absence, arm absence, and so
in my particular
orphan condition
is actually not one of the ones
that's listed on that site.
So I would say there
are probably more.
So the question is-- and
this gets back to the graphs
that I showed before--
because there's obviously
no market for it, it doesn't
necessarily make sense.
I wouldn't argue for example,
that it's a travesty that DARPA
didn't invest $100 billion into
solving this prosthetic arm
problem, because
the same could be
said for any of
these other orphans.
We simply can't
afford to do that
from a public health standpoint.
It's just not an effective
way to spend our resources.
So nevertheless,
feeling like this
is a problem that we'd
like for society to solve
and that it's not
the only one, this
is the question-- how can
we attack these problems
and solve some of them?
And it's clear that
we probably need
to think about them a little bit
different way than we are now.
My friend Chuck
Messer described this
as using your geek
powers for good.
The Cooper Hewitt Design
Museum in referencing
the 90% of the world it doesn't
benefit from our consumer
culture, they had a design
exhibit several years ago
called Designed For The Other
90% in reference to that.
There's another movement here
in the Bay Area for example,
you have a designer, an engineer
named Ralph Hotchkiss who makes
a wheelchair Whirlwind
Wheelchair is
in their organization .
They make appropriate
technology.
Wheelchairs that have larger
balloon tires on the front
to deal with uneven terrain
and broken sidewalks
that you're more
likely to encounter,
if there are sidewalks all in
a lot of the developing world.
And they have kind
of a cool model where
they try to set up factories
as profitable businesses
of social enterprise to
manufacture this wheelchair
design in the area where
they might be used.
And this in contrast
to sometimes
what gets done in a
wheelchair space for example,
is to send a kind of
rickety hospital wheelchair
over to that environment.
Where it lasts, like a lot of
medical technology over there,
about 10 minutes before it
breaks and then somebody
has trouble finding
a part to fix it,
and it ends up getting junked.
Whereas I'm arguing
that prosthetic arm
users in the United States
are an underserved population,
they're not disadvantaged,
certainly to the same degree
that patients of the
developing world are.
But all of these
patients are underserved
in some way or another.
So a good phrase
that's been used
to describe all of these
problems and the design
that we can use to
try to attack them,
is Public Interest Design.
Design in the public interest.
And so really what
I'd like to talk
about is, what are the
ways besides-- we'll
start off with government
sponsored research
because that's a lot of
what's happening currently.
What is our whole
quiver of tools
that we might use to try to
solve some of these problems?
Yeah, sorry about that.
What are the collection
of tools that we
could use to try to better
solve these problems?
And I, like lots of
people do, I think
I'll probably come down on there
being some combination of all
of these that are necessary.
But just to brush over
them all-- to begin with,
government sponsored research
and commercialization.
Then DIY and the maker culture.
Potentially an orphan
device law to serve
as a companion to
the orphan drug law
that we've had in this
country since 1983.
And then what other
regulatory or policy changes
might be made under
our existing structure,
but by program managers
who fund for example,
some of this government
sponsored research.
What things might they
do to try to raise
the impact of the
research funding
that they're
currently giving out?
And then secondly what can
we do in the private sector?
Are there ways that folks
in the private sector
might be able to
contribute in ways
that don't impact
their own bottom line?
And they can in a
potentially even
have a win-win in serving
these underserved folks.
So to start off
with, these are icons
that represent the three
major engineering research
efforts that I showed
the funding levels for.
The moonshot, the atomic bomb,
and the Joint Strike Fighter.
And it's certainly clear
that there are some problems
that government has
to solve, if they're
going to get solved for us.
While we do have SpaceX in
a commercial space effort
right now, it only exists
because the government
is choosing to create
that capability
in the fundings coming
from the government.
So that's an example
actually of sort
of spreading the stuff
around a little bit.
But it was clear that
sending a man to the moon
or building the bomb,
however you feel about
that having done, these were
certainly projects they would
never have happened had not one
of the largest and wealthiest
governments in the
world decided that they
were going to make it happen.
And they happen because in
at least two in these cases--
the first two that I
mentioned-- the results were
non-negotiable.
We were going to get to the
moon no matter how much it costs
and how dangerous it was.
Those who are in charge of the
bomb viewed it as a response
to an existential threat and
that failure was not an option.
The government probably
would have spent anything
to achieve these ends.
Now a lot of times some
of these very programs
and the other basic science
research that the government
does are cited as having
intangible benefits that
spin off, that we
would be without
were it not for
these other efforts.
So Tang, Teflon, and
Velcro are three.
And there's actually
a myth-busting page
on NASA's website that I
have up there on the slide.
It says that in fact, none
of these three products
were created by NASA or
NASA-funded research.
Although the space program did
take advantage of all of those.
While they used Tang,
Teflon, and Velcro,
they did not create it.
And I would argue
that even if they had,
building upon sending
somebody the moon
or building a high
tech fighter jet,
are not the most efficient
ways to create things
like Tang, Teflon, and Velcro.
So if what you want
is a prosthetic arm
or to put somebody on the moon
or to build a fighter jet,
that is what you do.
This really comes
down to the difference
between engineering
and basic science.
So the point is that
whatever efforts there
are that are devoted to
solving this problem,
it really needs to be dedicated
to solving the problem.
And there needs to be
some agreement on actually
what the problem is.
A significant component at
least the four-year DARPA effort
was based on the creation of a
neural brain-machine interface.
While in the long term
it's certainly true
that that represents
potentially a holy grail
of prosthetic arms,
it's not clear
that is a necessary
component of it.
Particularly given the
state of technology
that most people
are using every day.
So I was, at the time when
I met Michael in 2007,
we had a version
of this hardware
that we were showing
at Google SciFoo.
Tim Hanson is now
post-doc at UCSF,
and he created when he
was at the Nicolelis lab
at Duke University the signal
processing board, which
is capable of processing
16 EMG electromyogram
signals from the
surface of the skin that
can detect muscle movements.
And we designed it to have as
many interfaces as possible
because our goal
in this DIY space
was to try to encourage
experimentation
and to try to benefit
from the maker
culture and the huge
video game industry.
And hope that some of
those resources and efforts
and interest could rub off
and make some improvements
in prosthetic arms.
What we learned is
sort of the downside
to DIY maker and
open source culture,
was that these projects
sometimes require-- well first
they can't be done
completely without resources.
And then secondly,
there's activation energy
to any kind of a
collaborative effort, which
if you don't cross you have
a lot of difficulty making
anything happen.
So this project to still alive.
I looked they were
commits this week.
But all of those
as far as I'm aware
are coming from the two
labs at UCSF and Duke
that are using the hardware.
So the schematics-- all
this is open source and GPL
to the extent that it
actually applies to all of it.
The schematics are up there,
all of the masks, the firmware
for the board,
everything is there.
But as far as I'm aware, nobody
has actually made one of these
except for those
two labs that are
using it and active
contributors.
Tim made a pretty
complicated board.
It's like six layers and has
these tiny little vias and some
'04 components on it.
We made this thing in a toaster
and had some horrible moments
where somebody
breathed on and then
you can't tell what and of those
things are anymore, et cetera.
So as far as I know nobody
from the larger DIY or maker
culture has participated
in this project.
Now there's also there's another
part of the project-- we have
functioning pattern recognition
software in MATLAB which is not
open source, and again
this is another barrier.
In order to use the open source
software that we have up there
you need to have
access to something
like $20,000 worth
of MATLAB tool boxes.
Which you're only going to have
if you're in industry or you're
in academia somewhere.
So these again are
some of the barriers.
Beyond that, this hasn't really
had the impact that we really
hoped that it would
have when we started.
Although I'm certainly
proud we tried
and it's a pretty cool
piece of hardware.
Here's another one.
We had a little project on
the open prosthetics project
to recreate a
prosthetic hook that
was designed in the '20s which
has been out of production
for something like
35 or 40 years.
And most of the guys--
and it is mostly
guys-- who use this hook
are 80, 90 years old
and they live in the Midwest.
I think there are some
demographic peculiarities
about where this
thing was prescribed,
or what people
wanted to use it for.
And I still get calls from
people who find-- very few,
it's a trickle-- who find this
thing on the web and want one.
You can see here this is a
picture somebody-- [INAUDIBLE]
put this in the
Thingiverse and I
got bunches of people
who wanted to volunteer.
They were offering to print
as many of these things
as they could on their first
generation MakerBots-- which
is where I think this
printed hook came from--
to help the project.
But unfortunately, even the
latest generation MakerBot 2,
which I have and
really enjoy, it
doesn't print in
a material that's
appropriate for actual use.
At least in this design.
This is made to be a metal hook.
And you can see that the
resolution is really not
fantastic there.
What we discovered, that
one in the lower right
was printed using
selective laser sintering,
a rapid prototyping process.
And we had some tolerance
problems with that one
until the service bureau
actually printed the thing out
on a plate and then
machined off the plate.
The two jaws of the hook did
not fit together so we have
something like more than
50,000ths off on that thing.
And I bring this up
just to point out
the limitations of
some of these things.
Just to loop back for a moment
to the breathless enthusiasm
of the press for a
lot of these things.
I can't tell you the
number of stories
that I've seen in
the last two years
about a high school
student who has 3D printed
a prosthetic hand that is
supposedly better than you pick
the price point of
some commercially
available prosthetic hand.
There's really no scrutiny at
all that's applied to these
claims .
Very often there are
completely externally powered
like motors with strings or
maybe they're not even powered.
In any case, nobody really
closely examines the claim
that some kid has bested
a $40,000 prosthetic
hand in his bedroom
with a RepRap machine.
While I consider
myself to be a part of,
and I fully embrace
the maker culture,
I think we also need to be
very realistic about what we've
actually accomplished
and try not
to run victory laps before
we've actually done it.
And I and I think that this
probably is one of those cases.
Now that the happy
ending to this story
is that there actually is
a prosthetic company called
ToughWare.
They re-engineered this and
fixed some of the problems
that we had actually identified
with the original design.
I think you could
actually see it
in the-- that's an original hook
from many decades ago up there.
And you can see the
places it's been welded.
And so this company fixed
some of the problems
and where these
things were breaking.
I do believe that
you can actually now
purchase a version of this
hook commercially again.
I consider that to
be a success even
if we weren't the
ones who did it.
So lastly and then there
is some bleed across here--
Michael did reference the
company that I've started.
I also decided to
back up a little bit
and solve one of the problems
about prosthetic arms that
may be in fact the most vexing
and least addressed, which
is how we attach them
to people's bodies.
This is traditionally done with
a hard carbon fiber or glass
socket, a rubber liner and
maybe a plastic socket there.
And I would liken a
lot of these designs
to wearing wooden
shoes and rubber socks.
And it does pretty horrible
things to your skin
when there's moisture
and friction involved.
And heat, moisture, weight,
and perceived weight
is really related to
all of these things,
because people will tolerate
hanging less off of your body
when it doesn't really fit well.
It feels like it's heavier
if it's uncomfortable.
So we decided that
the way to solve this
was to go back to what
prosthetic arms used
to be like in the
'40s before the VA did
all the research that created
these composite sockets
and consider making prosthetic
sockets more like shoes.
Like athletic shoes.
Prosthetic sockets used
to be made of leather,
and I've been told
by old guys who
wear leather
sockets that they're
the most comfortable
thing in the world
and they would never
wear anything else.
But you can't find anybody
to make one of these things
now, because they're
really labor intensive.
And the VA actually do a
whole bunch of research
in the '40s trying to figure
out how to make them not stink.
Because they're
basically like shoes.
So we now have a pending
research proposal
that we should hear
from the army and DARPA
from any day now to use current
athletic shoe technology to try
to make a flexible, variable
compliance socket that's
stiff in some places
and flexible and others,
breakable everywhere.
That basically solves
all the same problems
that your running shoes do.
And this would address
the number one reason
that people abandon
prosthetic arms.
And that by the way,
actually includes,
for example one
of the DARPA arms
that was tested in VA clinics
among transradial patients
like me.
Comfort was actually
one of the major reasons
that I think about
half of those patients
said that they might not
be interested in having
one of those new arms.
So if we solve that
problem, then we
could potentially make a lot
of the other technology more
effective, because
will be better
at attaching people's bodies.
So that's what we're
up to right now.
An orphan device law.
So at the time that the orphan
drug law was passed in 1983,
we had a bipartisan Congress.
And I think that to imagine
in the current legislative
environment we can get anything
done may be overoptimistic.
Although perhaps
in an ideal world,
we would consider a law that
could increase innovation
and competition in this space.
Now for those of you who
are unfamiliar with it,
what the orphan
drug law does, is
it extends exclusivity
for a drug company
who's developed
a product but who
believes that the
further investment
necessary to actually bring
a proven drug to market
is not worth the investment
because their patent--
the exclusivity available to
them on their original patents
has expired.
Drug development is often
a really long process
and it's a race against the
sun down on the patents.
Now unfortunately,
I'm not convinced
that a similar model in the
even much smaller orphan device
spaces would
actually do anything.
Because exclusivity in
prosthetic arm patents is often
abandoned when
people decide to stop
paying the maintenance on
their prosthetic arm patents
after seven or 15 years.
So they're leaving exclusivity
on the table with regard
to patents in this
space already,
so would extending it
actually do anything?
And I'm not convinced it would.
So since we're not miked in
the audience, the question is--
is the approval process for
medical devices, prosthetic arm
specifically similarly
long as it is for drugs?
That's sort of a
complicated question
because it depends on
which class of devices
you're talking about.
The FDA has three classes of
medical devices, one, two,
and three.
The DARPA neural-sensing
system would
be a class three medical
device because it actually
involves an internal implant.
Most prosthetic devices
right now are class one.
And they're not only class
one, they're class one exempt.
Which means that they are exempt
from-- there are something
like seven or eight requirements
for class one devices.
And all but three
of those are ignored
for this group of class
one exempt devices.
So in fact and
this is something,
actually that
there's been some--
some of the folks who've been
pursuing these new things have
been assuming, and
they may be right,
that the FDA is seeking
to regulate prosthetic arm
stuff more rigorously than
they have in the past.
There are articulated
myoelectric hands
that have been brought to
market in the last five years
that were brought to market.
All you have to do basically
is announced to the FDA
that you're going to start
selling these things and do it.
And if you're going to test it
you just stamp it experimental,
and you're good to go.
But nobody wants to invest
hundreds of millions of dollars
in the creation of a
device unless they're
sure that they're going
to get away with that.
And the FDA had
been making noises
that they were going
to try to bump up
the classification of
some of these things.
And they also have a requirement
for orthopedic devices,
which is reasonable.
It's based on-- so a screw
in an orthopedic implant
is a class one device that's
a component of a class three
device, which is the implant.
And there was a bad
failure in the '80s because
of the changing of
these class one devices.
And so the FDA requires that
each class one component
be separately recertified
with the class three system.
And if somebody did something
like that for example
with-- say there's a bolt
that can go through your skin
into the bone, it's called
osteointegration, a titanium
bolt.
And the bolt of course
is a class three device
because it goes inside the body.
And if they required you
to separately certify
every prosthetic hand
or foot that you attach
to one of these systems,
it would effectively
mean that there
wouldn't be available
because nobody would
bother to do it.
So actually you bring
up a really great point,
which is that the FDA is a
really important part of this.
And some orphan device law, a
hypothetical orphan device law
or revisions of regulations that
might really impact the space
should try to remove
some of those barriers
that actually the
FDA could potentially
create in trying to
better protect us.
And then there are humanitarian
exemptions available.
And so this is
something that I think
there's further consideration.
So that leads into
the next group
of things which are
beyond new law, what
about the interpretation of
existing laws and regulations.
The Bayh-Dole act
is the law from 1980
that governs the
government funded
creation of
intellectual property.
And the part that most of us
are familiar with if you've ever
received a government grant
is that the government
has royalty free, nonexclusive
license to anything
that they pay you to create.
But then in order to
encourage economic activity,
anybody who creates the
stuff has the permission
to go off and license it,
do whatever they want,
exploit that intellectual
property on their own,
as long as they don't
charge any royalties back
to the government.
In practice I think some
of this actually goes on
because if they
fund-- particularly
weapon systems and stuff
like that-- it's not
like they segment off what
the intellectual property
component is.
It's not like anybody else can
make some of these fighter jets
or tanks or whatever.
So the least popular
provision of this law what are
called march-in rights.
Which means that if
the government-- there
are four criteria that could
be met where the government can
come in and say,
you are not making
use of this intellectual
property the way
we intended you to, we're
going to take it from you
and give it to somebody else.
It has been exercised
very few times, if ever,
and it's a very popular-- as
you could imagine-- provision
with people who could get a
lot of government funding.
How much time do we have?
So while this law
exists it is something
that could be made use of
that's on the books already.
Program managers could
say, OK it's been 15 years,
you haven't-- you created
a product where we're going
to find somebody who will,
because our goal is to bring
something like this to market.
And another one that
I referenced earlier
is the Center for Medicare
and Medicaid Services.
So all these devices and many
medical devices are like this,
are reimbursed as durable
medical equipment--
canes, walkers, CPAP machines,
and prosthetic devices.
And the weirdness
that this creates
is that the whole
cost of supporting
the device for something
like five years
in between replacements,
has to be captured just
in the provision of the product
at the beginning of its life
cycle.
All of the appointments
and everything.
So a prosthetist needs
to be able to to function
based on that.
The other thing that's
weird about this
is that there's a perverse
incentive of course
to provide more
up these products.
Because if you give
somebody a myoelectric arm,
it reimburses at $35,000 a
body-powered arm may be $8000.
And the other thing is that the
way that these reimbursement
codes are created is that a
company has to demonstrate
efficacy, and then
they petition CMS.
So that they have to basically
outlay all of the R&D
ahead, before they know
if they're going to get
reimbursed.
There have been some
recent cases where people
get the wrong answer back from
CMS and it kills the company.
A good example is
the iBot wheelchair
which everybody agrees is
pretty impressive technology.
That came back as being
excluded to a very
few pretty serious
disabilities and not
reimbursable at a rate that
could sustain its manufacturer
and the company's
closed its doors.
And so it's actually
up in the air
what's going to happen to
add to that technology.
Hopefully DEKA, which
is the creator of it,
will figure something out.
So one thing I think
people might do
would be to create incentives
in reimbursement codes.
You could create a code
for the performance
of a particular device without
knowing that it existed.
So I could say a 15 degree
of freedom prosthetic hand
and wrist that's capable
of all these performance
criteria will reimburse
at this rate-- $150,000
or whatever it is.
And then company would
know ahead of time
that they have a
payday ahead of them
if they're capable of
meeting the criteria.
And so it would be much more
clear that this is possible.
Then, contract language,
there's a bunch of open source
and open architecture language
that-- the Navy for one,
still has a kind of dead
website that's still up there--
but it's sample program
manager language
to put in RFPs to
ensure that you
can get what you
want out of them.
And those are tools
that could be used.
And then lastly the DARPA
has made really good use
of challenges and contests.
And I think the sort of thing
in partnership with industry
might be very helpful.
So I guess in some sense, in
my graphic here of somebody
cutting red tape,
maybe I'm actually
talking about creating
some more in some cases.
But you get the picture.
So what about industry?
And that's guys here at Google.
I think that Google has done
some really creative things
in terms of business model in
creating great products that
solve problems in ways
that people hadn't before.
And by focusing
the business model
in sort of unexpected
parts of it.
And so I think both the Android
operating system and Gmail
are good examples of that.
And a recent acquisition of
yours the nest company that
makes these thermostats and
the smoke detector-- those
are examples of products
where people would have said,
these are commodities,
you can't improve on this.
It is what it is and
everybody has to have one,
and you're going to buy
the $8.95 one instead
of the $9.95 one because it just
does whatever it needs to do.
And I think the way that
company was able to really pay
attention to consumers
represents creative thinking
which is the way that
probably everybody needs
to attack challenging markets.
And these ones I've talked about
are certainly some of them.
So you guys have
also been in the news
recently for-- by my
count something like nine,
counting the drone company--
robotic acquisitions
over the last year or so.
And one of these
is Redwood robotics
which I think involves a part
of a Willow Garage spin-off.
And I looked a
little bit, I'd never
seen this hand picture before.
It looks to me like a rendering.
I don't know if it
represents a real product.
I think that it's interesting
that in terms of a manipulation
and terminal device
a hand acquisition
that you guys chose to
acquire Redwood and not in any
of the companies that
were involved in the DARPA
prosthetic arms.
There's an interesting
companionship
between robot teleoperation
and prosthetics.
Myron Diftler, who runs the
Robonaut program for NASA
at Johnson Space Center said,
that when he thought about it,
the prosthetic
problem is basically
a teleoperation problem.
You just happen to be
attached to the device you're
trying to teleoperate.
So in some sense, when you
take away video latency
to the moon or whatever, the
prosthetic control problem
might be in some sense easier.
Although the way that
these things are usually
performed right now is with
sort of a haptic armature.
And in the prosthetic
case, obviously you're
trying to control a
limb that's absent,
so you don't have
access to those fingers
to tell those digits
where to move.
Anyway, my point
in bringing this up
is that there is some
great companionship
to these problems.
And in fact while it is
not clear right now who
in America is ready to buy, for
example, a personal assistance
robot, or some other things that
one might imagine as products
that could come out of companies
like these down the road,
there are prosthetic
customers who can,
according to the current
reimbursement system,
in some cases pay in
excess of $100,000 for one
of these devices.
So it might be possible to
create a synergy of interest
where you're solving problems
for the future of home
and mass produced robotics.
At the same time as you are
serving prosthetic customers
in the near term, even
though they don't represent
the huge revenue
stream that we all
would if everybody has a Jetsons
style maid in their home.
This is a picture
of my friend Kevin
who was born without
both of his legs.
I threw his picture
up there because he
is in some ways represents
an orphan of an even
smaller community than my own.
Without any hip joints, when
he was about 10 years old
they tried to put
prosthetic legs on him
and they weren't really
anything but another couple
of extra crutches for him
to sort of haul around.
And he very quickly decided
that he wanted no part of that,
and he gets around
on a skateboard.
Now that said, if you
were to envision--
and that's a way to
stay active too--
but if you were to envision a
robotic prosthetic device that
might help him, it
could look something
like Boston Robotics--
Boston Dynamics,
I forget the name of the
company in Cambridge--
they have the big dog walking
bot and those others where they
pretty famously kick
them over in the video.
A pair of those walking likes
controlled like the Segway is,
by leaning, could do pretty
fair bit towards replacing legs.
And so that's sort
of another case where
one of these robotics
companies might
hold in currently
available technology
the keys to making a
change in somebody's life.
My hope in mentioning
industry-- and I think again,
none of these are
mutually exclusive-- I
do believe that the only
way that we are going
to solve these extremely
vexing problems to society
is by throwing nearly
everything that we have at it
and seeing what sticks.
And so really my purpose
in talking to you
today is I want to start this
conversation because it's
pretty clear to me that there
are some things that we could
do better about how we're
responding to these problems,
and I'd very much like some help
in figuring out how to do it.
I used up more time than I'd
intended to, but if y'all have
any questions I'd certainly
like to try and answer them.
So the question is, I mentioned
that most arm amputees still
use hooks via the
more complicated
electrical externally
powered prostheses, and why.
I think cost is part of it.
The Affordable Care Act
has changed some of that.
Before January, a lot of
people with medical insurance
had lifetime caps of-- in some
cases like $1,500 lifetime cap
on prosthetics
services-- which isn't
even enough to get
a single prosthesis.
And beyond the
expansion of coverage,
the removal of
the lifetime caps,
and pre-existing
conditions are huge
for the prosthetic community.
So to the extent
that it is monetary,
the Affordable Care should
change some of that.
Anecdotally, I don't think
there's any great data on this,
but I think a lot
of common complaints
about the myoelectric
prostheses are
latency, unintended movements,
the speed with which the motors
move the weight, and then
I think you hit on it--
function is probably
the primary reason.
The hook has been famously
described in Ted talks
as a rubber band and a
hook on the end of a stick.
But I believe the
bar is actually
quite a bit higher than that.
The Dorrance hook is really
kind of a marvel of design.
It's got a bunch of affordances
kind of built into it.
You could pick something
up, use it as a hook.
And then as a split
hook you can open it up
and use the individual
fingers for different things.
The little thumb that
has the cable on it--
put that back up-- the little
thumb that has the cable on it
can be used to
push things, and is
the part of the
device that's used
to wedge a knife and a fork.
Actually that's a
perfect example,
is eating with a
knife and a fork.
With cosmetic coverings
on the myoelectric hands
they tend to be
slippery and it's
hard to get a knife and a
fork to set securely in them.
And this thing is designed
to do exactly that.
It's got a chiseled
tang in the middle
so you can stick
a tool in there.
Or you could wedge
either a knife or fork
in between the fingers
and over the thumb.
So I think function
is a lot of it.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
So, well first of all,
it's selfish of me, right?
That's my problem
so that's what I
spend a lot of time
thinking about.
But there are other
complications.
So there are something like
50 times more leg amputees
in America than arm amputees
because of peripheral vascular
disease secondary to diabetes.
And that's the major
cause of leg amputation.
So there are more than
two million leg amputees
in America.
And it's an easier
problem to solve too.
Well, Oscar Pistorius
is a great example.
The cheetah legs make somebody
capable of running close
to a 10 second hundred.
Although knees are a problem.
And Oscar Pistorius is
a below-knee amputee.
But then among the
powered devices,
control engineers
who work on legs
have told me that it's possible
to do reasonable approximations
of gait with the individual
components not even talking
to each other.
Where they just respond to
the external forces and they
are capable of doing a
pretty good job walking.
And contrast that to
an arm where just--
forget the manipulation
stuff-- just
reach to grasp with a
whole arm for somebody
up to the shoulder level
involves the coordination
of all of the joints together.
So I like to say that if you
imagine that these are legs,
the arm problem has five of
them on the end of a sixth
and they all have to
dance together in order
to do the most basic task
that an arm has to do.
Yeah and so the
economics are-- I
mean legs are a lot
bigger business.
So there is a real incentive.
Although there are
some new leg companies
that because of the high cost of
additional degrees of freedom,
there are some
leg companies that
are going to be in
trouble if they don't
get the reimbursements that
they want on powered ankles,
for example.
And so in that sense they
share exactly the same problem.
Anything else?
Any questions from
our remote rooms?
All right.
Well, listen, thank you very
much for taking the time
to check it out.
And I don't know if there's
a way for me to post contact
information, but if anybody is
interested in further talking
about this, please get
with Michael Weiss-Malik
and he'll put you
in touch with me.
Thanks very much.